hey what's up mrs. dr. John de Loney
with Ramsey Network we're back answering
emails about anxiety about your
relationships and these are your emails
that you emailed in a - John at Ramsey
solutions calm
keep them coming awesome how many emails
were getting man they are coming in and
coming in there's a lot of people out
there struggling including you including
me so let's do this together alright so
here's an email hello mr. John Bologna
what's up go to talk to you if you get a
chance to read this email I truly
appreciate your time and effort that's
what I'm here for
appreciate you I'm 27 married with two
children 17 months and 9 years old oh
that's a gap I'm very unhappy I have no
motivation no desire in my marriage and
my husband and I are not compatible nor
am i attracted to him I have been
married since the age of 19 it was
rushed I feel awful about the fact that
I would mess up my family and our goals
four years I've been going through
emotional and mental rollercoasters on
this topic I'm at the point of angry
depression misplaced reactions and just
plain meanness towards my family
especially my daughter my husband is a
great person he's fine with an unhappy
marriage because he says he can work
with it I know all the information isn't
here but please help all right so a few
things number one thank you for being
vulnerable and for sending in this email
this is a lot and it feels heavy every
alarm you have is going off right number
two based on your age looks like you got
pregnant at 18 my guess is you had a
picture of what your life was gonna look
like right you had a job you were gonna
have some husband you were gonna have
you were gonna have kids the house was
gonna look this way and you had these
pictures whether you whether you were
intentional about them or that they came
from the magazines and the home you grew
up in and the internet sites you went to
whatever it was you got a picture and
now you're 27 knocking on thirty you
have a toddler a ten-year-old a husband
who's a great guy he's a great guy
you're not attracted to him anymore you
don't feel committed to this thing you
don't have any motivation
and that tells me you're suffering from
grief you're just grieving that here you
are almost 30 and the picture that is
your life looks different from your old
picture so you've got two choices number
one like you mentioned you can blow it
all up you can decide you know what this
first picture that I had in my head of
this particular husband in these
particular kids in this particular house
in this particular town you can nuke
everything you've got and go chase that
and what I always tell people who choose
that option is this no matter what new
job you get no matter what new partner
you get no matter what new town you live
in the worst part about that decision is
that you go with you and if you haven't
grieved the loss of this picture if you
haven't grieved the fact that you didn't
get quote-unquote normal 18 to 22 year
old life whatever that is if you haven't
grieved the fact that man you got a
husband and a couple of great kids
I just came differently than you had
drawn it up if you haven't dealt with
any childhood shame or parents who were
a mad that you got pregnant or whatever
if you haven't grieved that wherever you
end up this unmotivated unhappy lack of
desire person's going to show up there
too the other option is this you're
married to a great guy sounds like you
love him you've got a ten year old and a
17 month old you are in it you are potty
training and brain training right I've
got a 10 year old I get it right you got
a husband who loves you who has just
said you know what even if this
relationship isn't perfect I want to
stay with you because I love you because
I love our kids you can work with that
so what I want you to do is to look
around your current environment and say
you know what my picture is different
but it's not a bad picture my kitchen
feels like it's on fire but when I wave
this smoke away it's not a guy who loves
me I got two Healthy Kids I want to work
on finding motivation I want to work
on finding desire I'm gonna get with a
counselor or a couple of close friends
that I trust and not folks who just read
pinterest quotes but folks who are gonna
hold me accountable to my life and I'm
gonna slowly begin to change my thoughts
and my actions I'm gonna start looking
in the mirror and saying I am a person
worthy of love I'm a person worthy of
dealing with historical traumas in my
life I'm a person worthy of getting a
good job just because you have a 17
month old a nine year old doesn't mean
that your dreams are over and you're
gonna look at a husband that maybe you
don't feel attracted to him right now
but there's something attractive about
him that led you to have two kids with
him to stay with him for this long even
if it was rushed I don't care what
happened in the past we're talking about
what tomorrow's gonna look like so I
want you to get with a counselor give it
a couple of good friends and begin to
draw a picture
don't write words draw an actual picture
of what tomorrow could look like with
these same two kids with this same
husband draw a picture of something you
can live into what is happiness what is
joy gonna look like and I want you to do
the transformative work not on your
kitchen you don't need a new kitchen
yeah a new chef you need to believe that
you are a person of value worth
believing in worth loving and then
you're gonna sit down with your husband
you're gonna share this picture and
you're gonna tell them I want to live
into this I want this to be a great
marriage I refuse to have a bad marriage
I refuse to have bad sex I refuse to
have kids that other people don't like
being around and that change starts with
you and I believe in you and you're in a
funky moment you're in a funky moment
but the light on the other end of this
isn't bright and it starts with you
deciding I want to be whole and I want
to be well and I want to be loved thank
you for being vulnerable and for writing
this we're all rooting for you and I
hope you'll email me back in a few
months six months and let me know how
great things have turned around this is
dr. John Delaney with Ramsey solutions
don't forget to subscribe to the shows
did it to your friends email me at ask
John at Ramsey solutions comm and I'll
talk to you soon take care